our world is filled with beauty but also
tremendous power there are forces of
nature on our planet that can wreak
incredible havoc
[Music]
destruction and devastation forces that
seem unstoppable but for every act of
nature there's a force that is equally
powerful the human spirit it's there in
local communities people risking their
lives to save the lives of strangers in
the flood the fearless rescue workers
going into harm's way to pull survivors
from an earthquake and the firefighters
tirelessly battling blazing forest but
there's another place where you can find
it even when the storm passes the global
community of countless researchers
scientists and explorers who strive
every day to learn everything they can
to predict prepare and help us survive
these destructive events the knowledge
they gain and the stories they tell
serve to remind us that there is another
unstoppable force of nature on this
planet much bigger than a hurricane and
earthquake or a tsunami its humanity
[Music]
you
[Music]